Chancellor Merkel has been here frequently over the past 16 years.
Matter of fact, she knows the Oval Office as well as I do.
But all kidding aside,
through this administration,
she's been there for four years— or for four presidents. But I
want to take a moment to acknowledge the historic nature of her chancellorship.
First woman chancellor in German history,
the first chancellor from the former East Germany
and now the second
longest serving chancellor since Helmut Kohl.
Here’s an exemplary
life of groundbreaking service to Germany
and, I might add, and I mean it from the bottom my heart, to the world.
On behalf of the United States,
thank you Angela
for your career of a strong, principled leadership.
And thank you for speaking out for what is right
and for never failing to defend human dignity.